[Musik]
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
ja heute zu einer weiteren episode
gemeinschaft mit luca staffel 2 ich geh
mal direkt nach oben weil ich gerade
schon gesehen habe dass die bäume hier
gewachsen sind das sieht ja richtig geil
aus die mittlerweile sogar noch viel
verrückter als vorher wer immer noch ein
paar mehr pflichten setzlinge überall
hin gesetzlich hofft man dass die auch
noch wachsen werden aber das sieht
wirklich schon sehr geil wenn man von
hier unten jetzt quasi einfach hochdruck
denkt man wirklich man ist mitten im
wald drin sehr sehr sehr sehr geil ich
würde allerdings sagen wir verdienen gar
nicht lange zeit meine lieben freunde
der mir wurden wieder zahlreiche sachen
in die kommentare geschrieben wie
beispielsweise blue kann man einfach
rechtsklick bei den süßwaren dann
[Musik]
okay ich hätte nicht gedacht dass die
teil nämlich trotzdem noch angreifen
allerdings so spare ich mir dadurch dass
ich die teile immer wieder hinsetzen
muss abbauen und hinsetzen und so weiter
und so fort deswegen einfach rechts
klicken danke danke danke da auf jeden
fall für den hinweis was mir auch
geschrieben wurde war super mensch du
hast so viel eisen jetzt mittlerweile
schon hier drin nimm das einfach mal
raus nimmt mir ein bisschen von den
tannenbaum stemmen und mach dir doch
endlich mal bitte ein schild ist ja
relativ easy einfach so zac und jeder
noch einen eisenwaren hintern haben wir
ein schild da kann ich ganz einfach die
fackeln wieder in die hand nehmen das
schild hier hin und dann haben wir in
der hand und rüberkommt mache ich
einfach warm
und so wie ich mich kenne schaffe ich es
dann trotzdem zu sterben was mir
allerdings auch noch in die kommentare
geschrieben wurde war luca du hast auf
deiner minimap irgend so ein komisches
dings angezeigt bekommen irgend so ein
ding und deswegen müssen wir auf jeden
fall noch mal runter gehen in die höhle
und was wir auch geschrieben wurde war
luca tropfsteine sind extrem wichtig
davon habe ich da welche mitgenommen die
ich kann
positiv
[Musik]
die kann ich wohl irgendwie anbringen so
und dann tropft da irgendwie was runter
und wenn ich da runter dann kessel
stehen habe dann tropft da immer wasser
rein und mit dem kessel kann ich dann
auch sachen irgendwie anzünden oder so
ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung ich
erkläre mir erstmal ganz kurz die elfen
und machen wir noch ein paar neue
fackeln hier vorne die kohle nämlich
auch noch raus kann ich also und kupfer
hier reinpacken und stecker kann ich mir
einfach aus den tannen holzbrettern hier
machen denn 30 fackeln reichen glaube
ich nicht aus ich bin ja immer ein
weltmeister im ausleuchten allerdings
sehen wir den rest dann einfach mal mit
ich nehme auch natürlich meine workbench
wieder mit falls ich ja und irgendwie
was schmelzen muss nämlich auch noch mal
kurz im ofen mit und jetzt
geht's wieder los meine lieben freunde
wir laufen wieder wohnen
ich dachte das geht besser ab darunter
wir gehen wieder runter freunde und
gehen jetzt zum ersten mal
in diese richtung hier vorne
warum habe ich mir keinen einmal
mitgenommen der eimer ist am start
freuen ich bin jetzt gerade mal kurz
hoch gegangen so dass ich mir hier
dilaver mitnehmen kann während die jetzt
hier runter fließt glaube ich auch mal
hier vorne das kupfer ab ich bin
gespannt ob ich überhaupt so viel kupfer
benötigen wie ich hier die ganze zeit
abbau und finde in einer höhle
allerdings schaue mal einfach mal die
lava fließt hier ab wir können direkt
mal hier an der seite ist ein bisschen
her laufen hier geht's auch direkt
wieder nach oben das ist immer ein gutes
zeichen weil wir dann einerseits wissen
hier ist ein anderer eingang noch in die
höhle sind wissen der
da ist meine pace
okay hier geht's auf jeden fall runter
hier vorne ist noch ein bisschen kohle
und hier unten ist es jetzt direkt sehr
krass dunkler geworden weil der die lava
weg ist von daher würde ich sagen hier
unten sogar noch mehr lava wir gehen
erst mal hier vorne in den gang rein
hier ist auch noch ein bisschen kohle da
unten ist wieder so ein komisches ding
da wo wir auch in die kommentare schon
locker das kann sie mit einer schere
abbauen ich konzentriere mich allerdings
erstmal auf die kohle und eine schere
habe ich jetzt leider nicht dabei für
diese komischen ranken allerdings sind
sie auch glaube ich nicht so wichtig
hier unten geht es richtig ab da war ich
weiß nicht
[Musik]
wenigstens hat er mir ein bisschen das
eisen freigelegt hier unten die kohle
habe ich jetzt auch mal abgebaut ist war
auf jeden fall echt eine menge die hier
vorne noch drin lag jetzt gehen wir mal
kurz wieder hoch hier vorne waren noch
mehr eisen allerdings muss ich halt echt
schauen nicht dass sie mir der lover so
ein bisschen mache ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal meine bruchsteine und
versuchen mich hier so ein bisschen dran
vorbei zu bauen und jetzt setzt sich
hier vorne einfach auch mal einen
bruchstein rein so dass die lava hier
abfließt und wir uns so ein bisschen
sicherer durch bewegen können ich habe
keine ahnung was das der film blog ist
auch ein ganz normaler bruchstein sie
sehen halt echt teilweise ein bisschen
komisch aus und das hier war auch
tatsächlich klar die wir hier vorne
schon an der ecke gesehen haben das
haben wir gerade zwei fliegen mit einer
klappe geschlagen trotzdem gehen wir
jetzt hier auch nochmal in die anderen
gänge so ein bisschen rein und leuchten
auch erst mal alles aus hier vorne
scheint allerdings nicht gross weiter zu
gehen denn der gang endet auch hier
vorne direkt also mal ganz fix eben die
ärzte noch mal abbauen wollen leute
verein wächst hier
[Musik]
wollte ich nicht wir setzen allerdings
mal direkten bruchstein rein so dass das
wasser hier aufhört zufließen und
bewegen uns hier vorne weiterhin den
gang rein das ist alles ziemlich offen
und wir machen
wieder in dieser höhle wir gehen
allerdings direkt mal hier links auch in
den gang rein neben der krippe komme es
hier ist nichts außer ein tropfsteine
nehme ich mal mit ich hab's noch nicht
immer noch immer nicht so ganz
verstanden was ich mit den teilen machen
kann allerdings schauen wir einfach mal
wo uns das alles hinführt hier geht's
auch noch rum weiter in den anderen
kleinen gang rein allerdings hier vorne
direkt endet ich nehme mal ganz kurz
eben eisen und kohle mit und jetzt haben
wir auf jeden fall diese beiden gänge
hier komplett ausgeleuchtet und erkundet
und da können wir jetzt hier vorne
rechts mal eben hoch laufen und schauen
was uns hier noch so erwartet die sache
ist allerdings
die sache ist meine lieben freunde dafür
wollte ich mich auch mal ganz kurz
entschuldigen ich
[Musik]
wohl nicht abgeschlossen
nichts was ich so viel masse wie es
gelassen außer creep hat diese noch ein
bisschen schlimmer ich wollte mich ganz
kurz für diese episode hier
entschuldigen meine lieben freunde denn
ich weiß ja dass die höhen expedition
folgen nicht so gut ankommen bei euch
wie beispielsweise entdeckungs folgen
und da möchte ich auch direkt sagen
morgen um 18 uhr kommt ein neues
entdeckungs video online also stellt
euch gerne timer morgen 18
[Musik]
komisch ist hier oder
oder bin ich
sie nicht gerade irgendwas komisch
schüssel angelaufen
[Musik]
ist das so kakerlaken
adresse
der kritiker bruder kommt mit an bord
sind nichtig
oder ist das ein europa
[Musik]
der zu viele beine
bleib bitte da hinten ich habe keinen
plan was das ist ich habe ja allerdings
mein buch dabei meinen wörterbuch von
tieren von alle aber ich dachte weg wir
schauen wir ganz schnell rein ich habe
keine ahnung was das für ein ding ist es
ist wirklich eine kakerlake im corporate
culture foul ins ex-frau und underground
the way form des online bugs im white
light that makes the world to predators
ich kann kein englisch
[Musik]
was hat viel zu lesen hier
ok der soll einfach mal da hinten
chillen
ich nehme immer noch die ärzte mit dir
an der wandsbeker
[Musik]
da hat er angst vor mir wenn ich zu ihr
hin laufe ja ok hat angst vor mir das
ist sehr gut also die kakerlake haut auf
jeden fall ab meiner lieben freund ich
wollte nur ganz kurz sagen noch mal eben
zu dem thema von vorhin ich weiß dass
diese höhen expedition folgen aber nie
so krass geklickt werden und nie so gut
ankommen bei euch wie beispielsweise
folgen wo ich irgendwas baue oder halt
meine welt entdecken und ich glaube
wirklich wir alle freuen uns auf die
erste richtige entdeckungsreise und die
wird schon morgen stattfinden ich möchte
dass nämlich relativ schnell machen weil
ich wissen will wo ich mich hier befinde
wo ich mich aufhalte was in meiner
umgebung hier alles noch so existiert in
meiner welt weil ich ja auch paar mods
installiert habe also ein paar
modifikationen wodurch viele neue
landschaft mit hinzugefügt wurden in
minecraft und deswegen freue ich mich
wirklich extrem krass auf die nächste
episode morgen um 18 uhr also stellt
euch einen fetten wecker oder abonniert
halt einfach meinen kanal und klickt auf
die glocke denn dann bekommt dem morgen
eine benachrichtigung sobald das video
online geht ich werde eine riesige
entdeckungstour machen und da freue ich
mich extrem krass drauf es wird sehr
geil ich weiß nicht was wir alles
erkunden werden ich weiß nicht was wir
alles sehen werden
auf jeden fall eine menge
eine spitzhacke ist kaputt gegangen und
daher kräftig mir mal ganz kurz die
ebene neue und wird jetzt auch noch
einmal ganz kurz die ärzte abbauen und
jetzt sprinten wir noch mal kurz hier
vorne eben in den gang rein und schauen
ob sich hier noch irgendwas befindet ich
habe allerdings auch schon oben auf der
minimap gesehen dass sie glaube ich
nicht mehr so viel ab geht doch
jetzt auch noch einen 3 richtung weiter
ich weiß nicht
warum
aber diese höhle ist so verwinkelt aber
mit so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ich vorhin sagen wollte war dass ich
an dieser höhle so geil findet dass es
überall so kleine gänge gibt und nicht
so einen großen raum sondern halt alles
ziemlich verwirrend klar das ist für
mich ziemlich
blöd
[Musik]
dass ich da hat die lava hingesetzt habe
ich dachte m lg move und ich halte das
skelett auch aber das hat irgendwie
überhaupt nicht klappt es mir
vorgestellt habe
der weiterweg hier
[Musik]
ich wollte ganz
entspannt
[Musik]
ich wollte ganz entspannt diese höhle
hier erkunden
und vor allem schauen ob wir irgendwo
diese alchemisten allerdings finden was
mir die kommentare geschrieben wurde und
jetzt ist hier ein verwinkelter gang
nach dem anderen alter ich weiß gar
nicht
[Musik]
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich überall hin
laufen soll
also leute das hier vorne ist ja der
eingang gewesen zu der höhle also der
ort von dem wir quasi das erstmal die
höhle betreten haben und in der letzten
episode bin ich ja nur in diese richtung
hier glaub mein gott
[Musik]
hat er mich dann erschrocken
der lässt sich auch gar nicht irritieren
dann nimmt einfach seinem blog und jetzt
kommt wieder jetzt bleibt er stehen ja
auf jeden fall sind wir in der letzten
episode nur hierhin gelaufen und ich
glaube dass mit diesem alchemisten ding
was mir unten in die kommentare
geschrieben wurde also dass hier
ich weiß aber noch nicht genau was es
ist aber ich glaube es geht um diesen
ort dort oben rechts wenn euch das
gerade bei hier ein bisschen run gesund
ich glaube ich muss mich irgendwie
hierdurch bauen um dahin zu kommen ich
sehe das halt nur bei die minimap und
finde halt gerade dass solche sachen
jetzt ein bisschen cheaten mäßig sind
ich bin angeblich direkt drin
so ist es jetzt unter mir
[Musik]
also wir sind auf jeden fall bei
irgendwelchen neuen glocken gerade
angekommen ich weiß auch nicht was das
hier für weiße blöcke sind
aber
wo bin ich
[Musik]
was jetzt dass
das ist einfach schöne töne
wie sein orgelspiel
was ist das
wo bin ich denn hier gelandet
was mit so kristallen ich weiß ich kann
ich die mit eisen spitzhacke
[Musik]
am meta meta meta schärpe
was
ich habe keine ahnung was das hier für
ein ort ist und was sich mit diesem
scherben machen kann ob man damit sich
irgendwie auf werkzeuge machen kann oder
was ich generell mit diesen blöcken hier
anstellen soll
aber es sieht schon sehr
krass hier so nach harry potter mäßigen
vibes ausfindig ich glaube diese teile
hier sind zu klein als dass man sie
abbauen kann man dann wirklich was
bekommt weil aus diesen auch noch zu
klein also die müssen glaube ich noch so
ein bisschen wachsen und nur aus diesem
großen teilen bekommt man diese scherben
so wirkt nicht raus ich weiß allerdings
nicht was ich jetzt hier noch genau
irgendwie
machen soll oder keine ahnung das wurde
mir hat sony kommentare geschrieben von
wegen dass das krass sein raum zu finden
und ich habe anscheinend wieder
geisteskrank ist glück hier meiner welt
allerdings würde ich sagen laufe ich
jetzt mal einfach wieder hoch den
crafting habe kann ich ja hier stehen
lassen den kann ich mir mit holz einfach
neu machen und dann sichern wir jetzt
erstmal die ganzen materialien und dass
wir uns dann wirklich in der nächsten
episode minecraft mit luca voll und ganz
auf die erkundungsreise konzentrieren
können den crafting table den ich nie
habe ich einen ofen vorhin abgebaut na
ja genau den hier den kann ich hier
wieder hinsetzen jetzt packe ich erstmal
ganz fix die ganzen sachen die ich mir
geholt habe also reisen etc hier in
meinem ohr rein und seid ihr auch mal
ganz fix meine item und dann würde ich
sagen meine lieben freunde haben wir es
in der heutigen episode dann auch hinter
uns gebracht diese höhle endlich mal
vernünftig zu entdecken wir haben
wirklich eine menge items bekommen hier
vorne berät das kupfer und hier berät
dann schnell das eisen leben zu ende
unsere rüstung ist noch fast voll unser
schild lebt noch und wir haben auf jeden
fall 18 erfahrungs level ich gehe jetzt
mal schlafen hier unten ihr hört schon
nicht gerade man hört auch das ein oder
andere monster oben allerdings erwartet
uns nur ein neuer tag der regen ist
dementsprechend ja auch vorbei und in
der nächsten episode
ich will gar nicht wissen warum habt ihr
natürlich
ne fliege meine lieben freunde wenn euch
die heutige episode minecraft mit luca
gefallen hat dann lasst kann einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke so dass er eine benachrichtigung
bekommen wenn morgen um 18 uhr die große
erkundungstour online geht auf meinem
kanal ich freue mich extrem krass wir
entdecken unsere welt ich hoffe ihr seid
auch genau so bleibt wie ich und
[Musik]